Hello everybody and welcome to a very special
mid-week version, video-taped, god help us, version
and above all Webathon version of the Reason Roundtable podcast.
I am Matt Welch joined as always, most always, by our super friends,
Nick Gillespie, Peter Suderman, and Katherine Mangu-Ward. Hello everyone.
Howdy. Hey Matt. Happy Wednesday.
People are gonna hear this on Thursday Peter so already you're wrong footing everything.
I hope you had a Happy Wednesday, if you're listening to this.
We are going to basically field  your questions, hopefully get to most of them,  I cannot promise that we will get to all of them.
The sooner we actually start askingthem the sooner we can get there. So first, before we start
I just wanted to see whether our Editor-in-Chief-dress Katherine Mangu-Ward has any kind of
objectivist prayer you want to say at the beginning of our Webathon session here.